if she just open that book I'm gonna be
a fat piece of [ __ ] so I can hang out
these people and be famous and that's my
thing just own it Amy Schumer on Jimmy
Kimmel you see it was in my Apple news
it was in my youtube trending feed
despite the fact that I did not click
anything I did not click a like icon or
a star he did not consent anything
similar that at all no there was zero
consent and it was thrust into every
news feed it's a question of the day I
like the word thrust is it beating a
dead horse or is Amy Schumer relevant
anymore I know that's kind of a mean
question but I guess the real question
too becomes and I want to hear your
feedback where does the comedy stick end
and just a terrible person begin and I
have a lot of leniency for comedy but
the difference is when you step out like
Amy Schumer has and shamed people on
Instagram and talked about being a proud
feminist and and in you know sort of
being this this I wouldn't say catalyst
but being an ambassador for the body
pride movement spokesperson at what
point is there some liability I take
responsibility when I actually try to
discuss factual issues or if I sit there
with Naomi Wolf I'm not just going to
make a joke if it's about something that
is actually statistically observable so
I want to know where that line is for
you in and whether it's blurred with Amy
Schumer but here's what it really
bothers me about Amy Schumer and I
realized what it is they hold her out as
this example of a strong example for me
not only feminist but for young women
and she is literally doing all of the
things that are guaranteed to make women
to lead young women into being unhappy
she encourages other women to engage in
behavior that will make them completely
miserable let's let's go to the first
portion I'm sure this won't surprise you
I
I know people just think like I stand on
stage and talk about my badge but I
yes
well it is on your LinkedIn profile some
may say that's a calling card
yes no no no nobody's ever like
confronted me like what's the
circumference of here I wouldn't go that
far and if someone takes a picture with
you you call harassment
[Laughter]
set your stopwatch it's 15 seconds
before it goes to that with Amy Schumer
it lets me be on the whole OneNote thing
though but right away what's the what's
one of the first things from askew 'ti
right being extra [ __ ] check which of
course we know leads to being more
unhappy but a lot of you thought before
we move on that Jimmy Kimmel had gotten
back under the comedy bandwagon like
okay it's a funny clip he wasn't joking
no we actually checked Amy Schumer's
LinkedIn brochure
yeah it's it's there if you look she
lists under strengths jokes about vagina
intercourse with strangers Old Navy
commercials taking offense filling
leather jackets playing victim and under
weaknesses face and then if you look at
experience she wrote everyman south of
36th Street and so that means well you
know what listen it was a layup for
Jimmy Kimmel so she's talking about
right
this whole [ __ ] thing if you look at
what I'm proud well I don't have to be
what what women have told me to be I
don't have to be a shrinking violet I
don't have to be in the kitchen well no
but you also don't have to be an
absolute predatory [ __ ] so hahaha
research found and you know what
actually I think people have gone back
and watch this I got an argument Amy
Schumer a while back I wrote a column
about how just personally my wife and I
we waited until we were married for
Christians like that that's what we did
you don't have to but I wrote about the
benefits of that and how it was a
societal tab but look at Amy Schumer
back then she was like by the way she
was like 30 then so I mean she was she
was she was cute she was cute enough so
it's what you see before he was clearly
a choice so researchers found the casual
sex is negative associated with
well-being and positively associated
with psychological distress there are
other studies we'll have all that you
can go search all these sources more
than a half of wives who would only ever
slept with her future husband felt
highly satisfied in their marriage the
portion dropped to 42 percent and then
almost plummeted to 22 percent for those
who had 10 or more partners these aren't
coming from from significance yeah it's
there is a statistical correlation not
if you just have sex with someone in a
long-term relationship like I said but
my choice doesn't necessarily have to be
your choice but it is statistically
undeniable that if you go around and act
like Amy Schumer you're probably going
to be miserable but there's more let's
go to the next clip you know I've been
do
TV and movies for a little and and you
have to you know not drink as much no it
doesn't matter but on movies really good
lighting if you were ever on the view
you know it just fully quality you're
just eyes in a floating head I've never
felt more gorgeous I feel like I'm
haunting the show I know I'm like I
might attend on the view and this is why
people don't respect her when it comes
to political issues it's not because you
don't know when she says you know I
never really knew anything about guns
but now I'm supporting gun control no
it's because your entire stick when it's
not about being [ __ ] is about being
superficial and vain all time that's all
you ever talk about until you decide to
get on your political or feminist
soapbox so so vanity check again we're
going down the list of things that'll
make young ladies miserable don't forget
she's a strong woman let's look up to
her or look around her let's go to the
next clip it kind of backfires I think
on the trolls cuz the other day somebody
tweeted about me Amy Schumer's body
looks like a bag of mashed potatoes and
I was like correct okay now I get really
hammered and you wake up late it's just
a good schedule that's great I had a
really cool way and last winter like has
anyone ever had the kind of weight gain
where like your coats don't fit you know
there's no I've never had it I don't
know I can't really be shrunk but if
it's like a pea coat
worry you if I gain or lose weight no
not a beginner lose weight but just
being in kind of a I don't know
unhealthy situation careful give you
constant feedback on your looks by the
way she sits there and she smirks but
you know it makes her misery oh she's so
mad too taking pride in being a fat bag
of potatoes which will make her extra
unhappy because of her superficial life
so you know what bothers her more
because everything is about vanity
everything is superficial it bothers
someone less if it's like a ha man I put
on a cup put on some winter weight but I
have a great wife I have a great family
I really feel as though I'm growing
intellectually emotionally spiritually
so you know I'll get back in the gym and
I'll get on this when you're whole thing
is I'm a [ __ ] and that's based on looks
which of course is just a deteriorating
commodity it's gonna make you extra
unhappy misbehaviour Oh
self-awareness to the zero force that
she has to just talk with things and you
got you know for her there's such a lack
of honesty SH because you know if she
just would say yeah I'm gonna own this
Marco to the comedy club because I can
take Roseanne Barr oh yeah because I get
to hang out with Jerry Seinfeld and
Steve Martin like she shows off anything
late if she just own epic yeah I'm gonna
be a fat piece of [ __ ] so I can hang all
these people over and be famous and
that's my thing just own it but don't
act like you're not like like that's not
your thing right I know yeah that is the
fake pride anything you want to add to
that bill look I'm clearly too fat to
becoming doing anything it's kind of sad
because she's in there joking like oh
yeah it's but you know it's not true and
she's obsessed for someone who's a I'm
at strong woman I don't care what you
think you talk about Twitter and about
comments online more than anybody knows
and that's not a dick enough of someone
who's mentally well adjusted which again
wouldn't be an issue if people weren't
holding her out as an example of a
strong woman guess what no surprise here
overweight women are unhappy they're
more likely to be depressed here's a
study obesity is associated with an
approximately 25% increase in odds of
mood and anxiety disorders
now anxiety seems self explanatory
because you're much more likely to die
that's at the top of your mind at all
times
your mortality men of normal weight have
an increased 19 risk of death women have
an increased 11% chance of death those
who are moderately obese that right that
obese that rises to 29.5 the statistics
people want to sit here and talk about
Amy Schumer I don't care what people
think if they think I look like a bag of
potatoes okay
your doctor does I don't care what
people think that I'm getting drunk
every night choosing my career path
based on this and I'm sleeping with
every Tom Dick and Harry in Manhattan
that I can find well that's fine your
OBGYN does we can't ignore statistical
realities and of course listen
biological realities as it relates to
women in order to try and falsely push
this idea an example of what feminism
should be to young women it by the way
if you're gonna try and pick an example
of someone to look up to for young women
feminists the [ __ ] 40-something year
old who picks a Broadway show so she can
drink all night and happens to be on the
edge of morbidly obese
probably not the number-one draft back
fat drunk and stupid is no way to go
through life stuff hey did you like this
video of course you did let's there's
something wrong with you in which case
you can comment below what's your
problem with this video we want to hear
from you and we promise you 100% I give
you my word as my bond will answer every
single negative comment for those who
are normal you can leave a thumbs up and
subscribe